in february jay z sold
fifty percent of his stake in brand
armando briniac
to luxury goods giant lvmh in a deal
forbes estimates to be worth
630 million dollars neither lvmh
nor jay-z have released the details of
the partnership but forbes estimates the
deal will land the brooklyn-born mogul
315 million dollars
the deal is huge and will push jay-z's
billion-dollar fortune
even higher but it's not the biggest
celebrity cash out
when fellow musician dr dre sold beats
to apple in 2014
the company was valued at 3 billion
earning him
585 million dollars pre-tax
and others in jay-z's orbit have also
made big bucks with corporate deals
jay-z's protege rihanna made a bulk of
her fortune from her makeup brand
fenty beauty the line is a partnership
between the singer and lvmh with rihanna
owning a 15
stake worth about 450 million dollars
she also has an 80 million dollar stake
in the lingerie line savage fenty
also a partnership with textile fashion
group kanye west cashes in on an
interesting profit-sharing agreement
with adidas
over his easy brand while west owns 100
of the brand adidas handles the
production marketing
and distribution west receives royalties
of 11
which forbes estimates was about 140
million dollars in 2019
on estimated revenues of 1.3 billion
dollars
kylie jenner's deal with cody inc for 51
of kylie cosmetics valued the brand at
more than 1 billion
netting jenner 540 million dollars
pre-tax
cody also teamed up with kim
kardashian's kkw
beauty which saw kardashian give up 20
percent of the brand
that made her 180 million dollars her
remaining 72
stake in the company is reportedly worth
500 million dollars
also on the beverage front george
clooney made big bucks when british
liquor giant diageo purchased the movie
stars tequila company casa amigos in
2017.
that deal valued the company at up to 1
billion dollars
clooney netted more than 200 million
dollars pre-tax on a deal that saw
diageo pay
700 million dollars upfront with an
extra 300 million dollars based on
performance over 10 years
for jay though the deal is still huge
and only complements his other monetary
assets
including roc nation's entertainment
business an athlete representation
agency
and a second liquor brand do say
[Music]